hätte es heute live schön dass ihr dabei
seid in lubmin tut sich wieder was da
kommt die pipeline nord stream 1 an hier
in deutschland und es kommt auch wieder
gas an aber nur 40 prozent dessen was
möglich ist und so lautet die frage die
wir heute stellen wollen reicht das aber
man muss natürlich auch fragen wofür
eigentlich soll das reichen um die
wirtschaft am laufen zu halten um die
gasspeicher zu füllen wir werden gleich
ausführlich darüber reden aber reicht es
auch um über den winter zu kommen und
nicht zuletzt reichte es auch um die
nervosität wieder zu beenden eure fragen
eure meinung könnt ihr gerne stellen wie
immer hier eingeblendet an diese adresse
zdf heute - live at zdf de wir reden mit
zwei namhaften experten ihr könnt die
fragen stellen ihr könnt eure meinung
äußern oder eben auch eure sichtweisen
denn wir wollen natürlich zum einen über
die fakten reden aber wir wollen auch
ein gefühl ausloten was mit diesen
gaslieferungen und mit der deutschen
angst die momentan herrscht einhergehen
was muss jetzt unternommen werden um
über den winter zu kommen um diese
gaskrise auch zu beenden
wirtschaftsminister habig hat heute von
einer trügerischen sicherheit gesprochen
wir sehen mal was er gesagt hat in der
tat nutzt russland seine große macht
eine zu große macht die wie russland
gegeben haben um europa und deutschland
zu erpressen und erweist sich jeden tag
als unsicherer kantonist bei der
energieversorgung in europa
so und zugeschaltet aus köln ist
professor mario ragwitz er ist der
leiter des fraunhofer eg einrichtungen
für energie infrastrukturen und
geothermie also ein fachmann was dieses
thema anbetrifft
herz wärmen es gerade gehört habe hat
sich eindeutig auch gegen russland
einmal mehr geäußert aber jetzt auch
gesagt der gasverbrauch muss weiter
runter die speicher müssen voll werden
ist das aus ihrer sicht machbar oder
sitzen wir in einer art russischen fall
ja ich denke es ist nacht da aber außer
außerordentliche herausforderung da wir
wie sie schon sagten eingangs nicht
diesen lieferungen von erdgas aus
russland bekommen sondern etwa 40
prozent in einem normalen jahr mit
nachfrage
entsprechend der typischen
wettersituation und so weiter verläuft
würde es mit diesem liefermengen äußerst
knapp werden wir haben allerdings in
diesem jahr schon deutlich eingespart
weniger gas verbraucht als in normalen
jahren und daher ist es von äußerster
bedeutung dass diese einsparung
fortgeführt werden werden wir sind ja
wie gesagt etwas 14 prozent weniger gas
verbraucht als in typischen jahren und
wir sollten diese einsparung reduzieren
wenn wir es schaffen die einspar mengen
auf etwa 20 prozent zu bringen und wir
gleichzeitig die erdgaslieferung aus den
nachbarländern norwegen niederlanden wie
vereinbart bekommen und gegebenenfalls
noch zusätzliche flüssiggas mengen
energie aus allen oder als übrigen
westlichen nachbarländern dann ist es zu
schaffen aber es wird äußerst
herausholen schauen wir mal auf ein paar
fakten die wir auch per grafik mal
einblenden zum beispiel eben den status
quo was den füllstand der gasspeicher in
deutschland anbetrifft nach dem winter
haben wir uns da ziemlich hoch
gearbeitet
es ist immer so im winter natürlich dass
die gasspeicher leer sind oder lehrer
sind im märz sehen wir hier waren es
noch 24 prozent jetzt aktuell sind wir
bei
65,1 prozent aus ihrer sicht ist das ein
guter wert reicht das
ja das ist ein mittlerer wert insofern
ist es erst mal beruhigend dass wir
dieses niveau in etwa erreicht haben
aber wie gesagt um weiter die füllstände
auf 75 89
über 90 prozent zu erhöhen wie von der
bundesregierung beschlossen ist es
einfach erforderlich dass wir weiter
deutlich mehr gas einspeichern bis zum
winter und es wird einfach davon
abhängen welche wie sich die
temperaturen bis zum winter entwickeln
wie beispielsweise benzinmengen auch aus
den nachbarländern fließen und
gegebenenfalls auch welche erneuerbaren
erzeugung wir bis zum winter bekommen
und damit der frage wie viel gas wie
beispielsweise im stromsektor
verbrauchen also insofern da gibt es
eine ganze reihe von unsicherheiten und
insofern kann man noch nicht geht ich
sagen dass es reichen wird um die
speicher bis zum winter zu füllen wie
gesagt momentan befinden wir uns da an
einem mittleren speicherstand und die
große herausforderung wird sein erdgas
jetzt ab sofort in allen bereichen
einzusparen wo das möglich ist jede
kilowattstunde zählt und wir haben da
eine ganze reihe von möglichkeiten
schwimmbäder haben schon angefangen zu
sparen die industrie verbraucht
natürlich aktuell weniger auch schon
aufgrund der hohen preise und wir haben
aber auch in privathaushalten im bereich
der wassernutzung beispielsweise größere
potenziale erdgas einzusparen schauen
wir noch mal auf die ziele die wir
angesprochen haben denn da hat die
bundesregierung heute in der tat machen
wir die stellschrauben angezogen auch da
vielleicht mal drei daten die an der
stelle wichtig sind um zu sehen wo man
hin will was die füllstände der
gasspeicher anbetrifft zum ersten
september ist geplant dass
75 prozent
die gasspeicher gefüllt werden sollen
und zum ersten oktober statt wie bisher
80 sollen es 85 prozent sein und zum
ersten november sogar dann 95 statt
ursprünglich 90 prozent die angepeilt
werden 95 prozent zum ersten november
warum ist das überhaupt so wichtig ich
nehme hier eine frage die captain nemo
via youtube stellt der meint wir sollten
das gas komplett auf null drosseln dann
hätte man eine konstante und das würde
ja ohnehin passieren denn putin wird
weiter drosseln und es wird kälter hier
und egal wie voll die speicher werden
wird putin sowieso das machen
das heißt ist das ist dass ein umgehen
mit dem mit dem aggressor putin dass man
sagt was er in der ukraine macht ist das
eine hauptsache unsere speicher sind
voll oder kann man kann deutschland sich
das überhaupt leisten anders vorzugehen
naja große teile unserer wirtschaft
basieren
erdgasbedarf die chemische industrie
natürlich insbesondere aber auch mit
vielzahl von unternehmen im
verarbeitenden gewerbe im bereich der
prozessindustrie und daher ist es schon
erforderlich dass wir weiterhin gas
erhalten wir haben ja zum glück noch
andere gaslieferanten das heißt das
nicht würde nicht sofort ausgehen wenn
russisches gas sofort auf null
reduziert wurde oder die die
importmengen von russischem gas
allerdings ist es so dass wir eben über
den winter deutlich höhere gas
verbräuche haben weil dann letztendlich
der heizenergiebedarf dazu kommt und
insofern ist es wichtig was die
bundesregierung macht dass sie hohe
speicher für stände zu beginn des
winters fördert weil nur so von mir dann
tatsächlich über die monate dezember bis
märz um gleichzeitig den industriellen
und den prozessoren bedarf als auch die
heizenergie zu decken schauen wir noch
mal ich habe die ziele von genannt also
erst im november jetzt 95 prozent
momentan das war ja der einstiegssatz
werden 40 prozent über nord stream 1
geliefert bis gestern waren die
erwartungs arbeiten deswegen war man ja
so gespannt wie es denn ab heute
weitergeht es fließen momentan 40
prozent durch diese pipeline aber damit
wir das noch mal verstehen ist ja eine
prozentzahl wofür wofür reichen denn 40
prozent reichen diese 40 prozent um den
bedarf der täglichen industrie zu decken
weil heizen ist ja das eine aber die
industrie braucht jeden tag gab es für
für energie potenziale also wofür
erreichen diese 40 prozent werden die
dann sowieso verbraucht oder oder kann
man mit diesen 40 prozent überhaupt noch
was abzwacken um die gasspeicher weiter
zu füllen
ja wir haben ja momentan etwa zwei
drittel unserer erdgas visum nicht aus
russland sondern aus norwegen aus den
niederlanden laden in zukunft auch aus
weiteren europäischen
nachbarländern und auch aus algen
lieferungen nach europa und insofern die
gaslieferungen aus russland nur das
verbleibende drittel aktuell und von
diesem mittel werden also in der durch
den aus dem einst pipeline
reduzierte mengen in dem 40 prozent
geliefert und bin sommer es ist schon so
dass die summe der gaslieferung
insgesamt über dem bedarf liegt und wir
insofern
zusätzliche mengen zur einspeicherung
versuchte haben das ist in jedem fall so
die frage ist ob die speicher
geschwindigkeit hoch genug ist das heißt
ob wir pro tag genügend mengen
einspeisung speichern können um die
ambitionierten speicher so stand's ziele
die sie grad genannt haben dann auch bis
zum winter zu erreichen und schauen wir
uns schauen wir uns vielleicht ist
gerade passt wenn ich kurz unterbrechen
darf weil es gerade passt zu dem was sie
sagten auch dann noch schnell eine
grafik mal an um zu sehen wie komplex
dieses netz auch ist und von wo überall
gas kommt denn dort sieht man was aus
russland geliefert wurde auch im
vergleich anfang des jahres im vergleich
zu jetzt so floss es also und bedeutete
55 prozent anfang des jahres kamen aus
russland von dem gas das wir brauchen
momentan sind es 29 prozent eben
aufgrund dessen was aus norwegen und den
niederlanden sie haben auch andere
beispiele genannt geliefert wird dadurch
konnten wir also sozusagen das was wir
momentan in deutschland verbrauchen in
bezug auf russisches gas auf 29 prozent
senken was anfang des jahres noch 55
prozent waren jetzt haben sie vom
frauenhofer ig ein gutachten vorgelegt
und dieses erdgasnetz dass wir da gerade
auf der grafik gesehen haben kein allzu
gutes zeugnis aus gelegt im sinne dessen
was wäre wenn kein russisches gas mehr
fließt demnach ist dieses erst
erdgasnetz nicht für fit für die
versorgung ohne russisches gas in wie
fern
genau dieses etwas nettes einfach für
andere schluss situation ausgelegt das
ist dafür gebaut dass die erdgas busse
aus russland von ost nach west wissen
deutschland ist ein wesentliches
transitland das heißt wir sind auf die
russischen gas flüsse angewiesen die
dann auch nach westeuropa weiter
transportiert werden und was wir nun
brauchen ist im grundsatz eine umkehrung
der typischen gas größe starts von ost
nach west werden wir jetzt mehr gas von
west nach ost und von süden nach norden
transportieren müssen und hierfür sind
änderungen in der gas infrastruktur
anpassung erforderlich insofern wir
haben ein sehr gut ausgebautes gasnetz
und das ist auch eine der wesentlichen
assets der die die wir letztendlich
nutzen können um die versorgung im
winter aufrecht zu erhalten und in den
nächsten jahren sind allerdings
anpassungen erweiterungen und
zusätzliche
ausbaumaßnahmen an diesem erdgasnetz
erforderlich und es sind einfach auch
zusätzliche
stellen in den nets erforderlich eine
der wesentlichen fällen sind
flüssiggasterminals die in verschiedenen
europäischen ländern gebaut werden und
ja auch in deutschland in der planung
sind genau auch dazu gibt es eine frage
wie ein youtube wie weit sind denn diese
lng terminals bzw der bezug von gas aus
anderen quellen aber bleiben wir mal bei
diesen lng terminals die sind geplant
was ist realistisch und wie viele
brauchten wir um tatsächlich noch ein
stück weit unabhängiger zu werden
ja ich denke die aktuell geplanten und
in der umsetzung befindlichen terminals
lassen ganz gut das zeigen unsere
rechnung um die versorgungssicherheit
dann bis 2025 vollumfänglich wieder
herzustellen es sind momentan zwei
sogenannte rss news schwimmende
flüssiggas legalisierung des terminals
geplant in brunsbüttel und willens hafen
die können wenn es gut läuft schon im
nächsten winter oder eben später sind
nächstes jahr 2023 liefern und
einsatzbereit sein und dann werden
weitere terminals bis zum jahr 2025 und
26 errichtet dabei insbesondere ein
großer flüssiggas terminal in stade und
aktuell in der diskussion in lubmin auch
ein weiteres flüssiggas terminal und mit
diesen vier terminals in deutschland
können wir eine recht gute
versorgungssicherheit herstellen wenn
auch andere maßnahmen erfüllt werden das
sind das erstens haben wir weitere
flüssiggas terminals etwa
10-15 terminals in anderen europäischen
ländern momentan in der planung im bau
in der umsetzung und wir haben auch die
aktuellen flüssiggasterminals nicht voll
ausgelastet in den nachbarländern das
heißt eine volle auslastung
und
letztendlich vollumfänglicher betrieb
dieser
flüssiggasterminals wird helfen und dazu
kommen letztendlich ausbaumaßnahmen an
den infrastrukturen aber dazu kann ich
vielleicht vielleicht noch ein bisschen
was ja genau denn bei diesem bei diesem
netz von dem wir davon gesprochen haben
und dass wir ja auch gesehen haben in
der grafik sagen sie in ihrem gutachten
wenn die kälteperiode richtig einsetzt
haben wir eine leistungslücke von 30
prozent in deutschland 25 prozent in
europa war 30 prozent in deutschland
ohne russisches gas und was ich ganz
spannend fand das gilt auch bei einer
vollständigen befüllung der
erdgasspeicher das heißt die
erdgasspeicher allein helfen uns auch
nicht wenn das netz drumrum nicht dafür
ausgelegt ist sozusagen das gas dann
auch entsprechend verteilen zu können
ist das richtig
richtig der studie haben wir angenommen
dass das closing die russischen
lieferungen komplett eingestellt werden
und unter dieser annahme auch für den
teil dass die speicher im winter zu
beginn ist wenn das vollumfänglich
gezählt sind hätten wir diese
leistungslücke versorgungslücke von etwa
30 prozent in deutschland für den
nächsten winter was jetzt erforderlich
ist um diese versorgungslücke zu
reduzieren in den nächsten jahren ist
dass wir erstens entlang auf der
sonstigen klimaschutzbemühungen unsere
erdgasbedarfs reduzieren da das bedeutet
erstens dass wir erneuerbare energien
deutlich schneller ausbauen müssen
energieeffizienz maßnahmen umsetzen und
sogenannte sektor kopplungs optionen
vollumfänglich umsetzen hier zählt
insbesondere dazu dass wir sehr hoch
effiziente wärmepumpen im wärmesektor
einsetzen und dadurch die erdgas bedarfe
für die wärmeerzeugung deutlich
reduzieren wenn wir diese bedarfs-
reduktion umsetzen und zweitens
infrastrukturmaßnahmen dazu gehören
insbesondere ausbau von sogenannten
interkonnektoren also die verbindung
zwischen deutschland unseren
nachbarländern und anderen staat in
europa verstärken und drittens auch die
schluss umkehr der verdichterstation
zwischen den ländern realisieren die
heute dafür gebaut sind erdgas von ost
nach west zu pumpen wer also diese
verdichterstation so umbauen dass sie
auch erdgas von westen nach osten pumpen
können dann schaffen wir es bis zum jahr
2025 spätestens die versorgungslücke auf
null zu reduzieren
das sind aber eben die kombination aus
einsparbemühungen die wir auch ohnehin
umsetzen und durchführen müssten
aufgrund der klimapolitischen maßnahmen
und der angesprochenen infrastruktur
infrastrukturellen maßnahmen sicher
ansprache vor allem haben wir verstanden
es ist nicht einfach ist es nicht damit
getan dass russland gas liefert oder
eben wenn kein gas geliefert wird dass
man da einfach sagt er dann holen wir es
woanders her das ist ein sehr komplexes
thema und sie haben schon gesagt bis
2025 auf jeden fall noch viel zu tun wir
haben eine vorstellung gewonnen dafür
dass es nicht damit getan ist jetzt die
gasspeicher zu füllen sondern wir müssen
mittel und langfristig denken danke erst
mal bis hierhin an dieser stelle
mario ragwitz für diese information und
einordnung aus köln dankeschön
ja wir haben es gerade gesetz gerne wir
haben es gerade also gesehen und schon
gehört es sind einerseits strategische
überlegungen die ganz wichtig sind aber
es gilt natürlich auch kurzfristige
maßnahmen zu ergreifen wir reden über
den notfallplan gas es gibt drei stufen
und wir sind bereits in der 2 thomas
ganze jahr fast mal zusammen was man
darüber wissen muss
im notfall plan gas wurde im märz die
früh warnstufe ausgerufen ein krisenstab
bewegt seit gut zwei wochen gilt die
alarmstufe
die gasversorgung gestört mehr
kohlekraftwerke sollen laufen um erdgas
bei der stromproduktion einzusparen wenn
das nichts nützt kann die
bundesregierung die notfall stufe
ausrufen dann entscheidet der staat über
die verteilung oberstes ziel aller
stufen verhindern dass er heizperiode
das gas knapp wird wo was das gebot gas
sprachen wie viel dazu schlägt jetzt die
eu kommission konkrete vorgaben vor ihr
plan alle mitglieder sollen bis ende
märz 2023 15 prozent weniger gas
verbrauchen zunächst freiwillig reicht
das nicht man könnte die eu die staaten
demnach zum gas sparen zwingen denkbar
sind vorgaben zum heizen und kühlen etwa
von öffentlichen gebäuden zb von leib
büchereien damit dann nicht die
schwächsten leiden sagt die eu
krankenhäuser und weitere schützenswerte
einrichtungen sowie private haushalte
müssen weiter gas bekommen geschützt
werden sollen aber auch
industriezweige die für versorgung und
wirtschaft essentiell wichtig sind
und ich begrüße jetzt frau professor
veronika grimm schönen guten abend sie
sind mitglied im sachverständigenrat zur
begutachtung der gesamtwirtschaftlichen
entwicklung oder wie man so schön sagt
sie gehören zu den fünf
wirtschaftsweisen guten abend schön dass
sie da sind
ja für wie weise halten sie das was die
bundesregierung da heute als neues
energiepaket verkündet hat
wir sehen ja schon die ganze zeit wir
sind in einer sehr herausfordernden lage
und die bundesregierung tut jetzt auch
sehr sehr viel um diesen notstand
irgendwo allerdings eine große glocke zu
verhindern ich glaube das ist auch
richtig so es ist auch wirklich richtig
dass wir einsparen das sind sowohl in
der verstromung von biogas verstromung
von gas als wir müssen gasverstromung
durch kohleverstromung ersetzen wir
müssen bei den haushalten einsparen da
sind ja auch verschiedene maßnahmen und
vorgeschlagen worden und wir müssen bei
den unternehmen einen spannenden ging
mehr wir sparen desto geringer ist am
ende die gas lücke die wir erwarten
müssen falls das gas tatsächlich knapp
wird gehen wir mal auf ein paar punkte
an sie haben schon genannt was da heute
verkündet wurde habeck sprach davon dass
bestimmte räume und flure nicht mehr
geheizt werden müssten verstärktes
arbeiten im home office damit büroräume
nicht mehr geheizt werden müssen die
eigentümer von gasheizungen sollen ein
heizungs check machen müssen
verpflichtend ein hydraulischer abgleich
soll verbindlich werden damit heizwasser
optimal verteilt wird und private pools
sollen nicht mehr mit gas beheizt werden
das sind alles kleine elemente machen
sie zusammen wirklich wirkungsvoll etwas
aus
wenn man das tatsächlich durchsetzen
kann dann macht das wirklich was aus
gerade bei den heizungen es ist auch bei
sehr jungen
gasheizungen so dass die nicht immer
optimal eingestellt sind und hier muss
man aber sehen dass immer der zeitliche
vorlauf aufgebraucht wird es dafür alles
der handwerker die dann entsprechend
kommen und die gasheizung einstellen
oder das überprüfen und hier brauchen
wir eben noch einen gewissen vorlauf
damit diese ganzen heizungen auch
überprüft und eingestellt werden können
außerdem ist es natürlich nicht ganz
einfach die menschen gerade die privaten
haushalte im detail dazu zu bekommen
diese maßnahme umzusetzen
hier könnte man neben den maßnahmen
vorgeschlagen sind auch mit prämien
arbeiten dass man einfach prämien aus
schreibt für diejenigen die besonders
viel sparen das könnte man zum beispiel
machen indem man den verbrauch im
kommenden winter vergleich mit dem
verbrauch im letzten winter und dadurch
noch mal sozusagen den ehrgeiz der
menschen auch weg gas einzusparen
insgesamt müssen wir eben sehr schnell
sehr weit kommen im haushaltsbereich ist
das sehr herausfordernde aufgrund der
kleinteiligkeit bei der verstromung von
gas könnte man auch darüber nachdenken
die kohlekraftwerke gleich laufen zu
lassen und mich erst ab oktober
man hätte das eigentlich im märz auch
schon anstoßen können denn auch da
können wir natürlich gas einsparen indem
wir im gewissen umfang die
kohlekraftwerke laufen lassen anstatt
der gaskraft dazu vielleicht noch die
braunkohle reserve die sich gerade an
sparen die wir zum ersten oktober
aktiviert bei der steinkohle gilt das
schon ziel des ganzen ist es die
stromerzeugung der gaskraftwerke zu
ersetzen täuscht das ein bisschen wenn
man all das hört und liest und
wirtschaftsminister habe ich ja auch
davon gesprochen als grüner politiker
wie sehr ihn das einerseits schmerzt
dass insgesamt von grüner energie
momentan zu wenig die rede ist
das ist ja eigentlich
beobachten wir sehen dass tagtäglich wie
an den flughäfen bei der deutschen bahn
überall fehlt es an fachkräften auch in
der gastronomie und das ist natürlich
auch so mit blick auf den ausbau von
erneuerbaren energien anlagen da gibt es
hemmnisse wir können nicht von heute auf
morgen so viel ausbauen wie wir gerne
würden und deswegen müssen wir jetzt
natürlich die kohlekraftwerke laufen
lassen um die gasverstromung zu
reduzieren und wir müssen jetzt auch
darauf achtgeben dass das nicht
dauerhaft so sein wird weil natürlich
auch in den kommenden jahren noch nicht
so viel erneuerbare ausgebaut sind dass
wir ohne probleme auf der basis von dem
verbleibenden gas und den erneuerbaren
und stromnetz betreiben können unser
stromsystem betreiben können sondern wir
werden weiter in der kohleverstromung
umfangreichere kohleverstromung
beobachten und da müssen wir natürlich
sehen dass wir das im rahmen halten
deswegen gibt es ja auch die debatte
darum die atomkraftwerke noch einmal um
fünf jahre zu verlängern um eben in den
kommenden fünf jahren nicht in dem
umfang kohle zu verstromen in dem das
sonst der fall wäre
dj fragt wie youtube eine allgemeine
frage eine wissens frage können wir
schnell beantworten ob fernwärme
eigentlich automatisch auch gas bedeutet
und einander von christoph 8 kommentare
auf facebook sagt wir sollten uns mal in
erinnerung rufen dass wir eine komplette
neue pipeline haben die nur aus
politischen gründen nicht in betrieb
genommen werden kann er spricht von nord
stream 2 wenn man also einerseits so zu
sagen schaut 40 prozent kommt jetzt
durch nord stream 1 und man hofft dass
das so bleibt andererseits schaltet man
aus politischen gründen nord stream 2
gar nicht erst an ist da nicht auch eine
gewisse bigotterie drin
unterschiedliche fragen
natürlich
das heißt auch im umkehrschluss dass
eben nur ein teil der gaskraftwerke
tatsächlich durch die kohleverstromung
reduziert werden kann in der verstromung
aber das ist ja zumindest schon mal
etwas mit blick auf nord film zwei das
ist natürlich eine komplett andere frage
da ist die frage wie stellen wir uns
eigentlich dieser aggression russlands
gegen die ukraine ein land in mitten in
europa und da ist natürlich sehr
verständlich dass man auch die
handelsbeziehungen mit russland daran
gekoppelt dass sich alle parteien daran
halten auf der grundlage einer
regelbasierten weltordnung miteinander
zu agieren und nicht zu fassen mit hilfe
von militärischer gewalt die eigenen
ziele durchzusetzen
und ich glaube dass es durchaus
plausibel dass es da eine klare reaktion
in richtung russland gibt dass man das
projekt hier an der stelle beendet hat
und es gab ja auch viele überlegungen
auch bei den restlichen gasimporten
durchaus dieser hohen gewinne die
russland aufgrund der hohen preise macht
zu beschränken hier hat man nicht
gezogen hier
liefern wir bezieht man immer noch das
gas zu den aktuellen preisen hofft
darauf dass das gas kommt
jetzt sehen wir dass ist nicht sicher
russland ist kein verlässlicher
handelspartner mehr und darauf müssen
wir uns jetzt einstellen und das wohl
dauer wir haben vorhin schon gehört in
dem beitrag und wir sehen es jetzt noch
da will ich darauf hinaus die
verbraucher werden mehr zahlen müssen
die gesetzgebung hat die weichen schon
dahingehend gestellt und tut es noch
herrscht hitze aber werden wir bald
schon kalt erwischt und was ich hier aus
den kommentaren immer wieder raushören
rauslesen wird was die preise an
betrifft
ja die preise werden steigen und ist das
noch nicht ganz geklärt in welchem
umfang und wie genau die preise
weitergegeben werden können darüber wird
ja gerade auch noch beraten in der
bundesregierung ist auf der einen seite
im gespräch dass tatsächlich die preise
weitergegeben werden können auf der
anderen seite ist ein umlageverfahren im
gespräch so dass eben nicht nur die von
den starken preissteigerungen
betroffenen versorger ihre preise an die
verbraucher und an die abnehmer
weitergeben sondern dass diese
preissteigerung und umgelegt werden auf
alle dafür spricht in gewissem sinne
schon etwas weil sonst natürlich die
preissteigerung sehr unterschiedlich
sind die einen werden immense
preissteigerungen erfahren die anderen
gar keine und dieses umlageverfahren
würde dazu führen dass jeder im gewissen
umfang preissteigerungen erfährt und
dann müsste man natürlich gucken dass
man im gegenzug die menschen entlastet
aber vermutlich hat man auch nicht alle
entlasten können diejenigen die sich das
leisten könnt ihr ein hohes einkommen
haben werden ein teil dieser hätten
tragen müssen man muss auf jeden fall
darauf achten dass man diejenigen die
eben ein niedriges einkommen haben und
diese härten nicht abfedern können aus
eigener kraft dass man die gezielt
entlastet und das wird eine
herausforderung aber man sollte hier
gezielt kompensieren durch die zahlungen
mit diesem hilfszahlungen beschäftigen
uns gleich schauen aber einmal was es
eben bedeutet am beispiel juniper dass
dieser dominoeffekt aus einer feld und
andere mit sich reißt nicht eintritt
ein riesen braucht hilfe juniper
deutschlands größter gasimporteur
zuletzt ohne gas aus russland juniper
musste teuer woanders einkaufen jetzt
könnte der bund einsteigen rettung mit
weiteren milliarden euro und die
gestiegenen gaspreise könnten
möglicherweise auch an die kunden
weitergegeben werden durch zwei neue
instrumente im energie sicherheitsgesetz
erstens dass preisanpassung sell epd den
versorgern mehrkosten schnell an die
kunden weiterzugeben alte verträge sind
dann hinfällig auch eine preisgarantie
gilt nicht mehr für die kunden wird es
teurer all den muss aber die
bundesnetzagentur zustimmen noch
umfassender ist zweitens das
umlagesystem hier müssen nicht nur
kunden schwächelnder versorger mehr
zahlen sondern alle ein solidarprinzip
vorbild die jetzt entfallene eeg umlage
in vorleistung könnte aber erstmal der
bund gehen
und das tut er über die kfw mit
wahrscheinlich acht milliarden euro 30
prozent so heißt es werden von dem bund
übernommen wenn er einsteigt bei juniper
um das unternehmen zu retten
rechnet sich das oder wächst der unmut
sie haben vorhin schon beispiele genannt
was getan werden muss und dafür eine
gewisse soziale gerechtigkeit zu sorgen
wie kann man die tatsächlich herstellen
eine vierköpfige familie fühlt sich
wahrscheinlich im recht aber auch
vielleicht ein alleinstehendes paar das
in einem irgendwo ländlichen raum in
einem großen haus wohnt wie kann man da
wirklich gerecht sein nach welchen
kriterien sollte man da vorgehen
jetzt nächste mal ist glaube ich fraglos
aktuell gibt es aufgrund dieser
entwicklungen liquiditätsproblemen man
muss das gas aus russland zu sehr hohen
börsenpreisen aktuell am markt einkaufen
um seine kunden beliefern zu können und
das bedeutet natürlich dass salz täglich
millionen an verlust gemacht werden und
solange die preise nicht weitergegeben
werden können bekommt dann natürlich
stück für stück oder ein ähnlicher
versorger die ihnen dasselbe problem
trifft dann stück für stück ein massives
liquiditätsprobleme und hier ist
natürlich klar dass man die versorgung
aufrecht erhalten sollte weil die
natürlich der worst case ist dass die
versorgung dann unterbrochen wird und
dann entsprechend diejenigen die hier
beliefert werden alle keinen gas
bekommen oder es andere komplikationen
gibt insofern muss man juniper da helfen
sicherlich und dann fragt sich eben in
welchem umfang man helfen muss man kann
über kredite gehen wenn man denn dann
die preise an die kundinnen und kunden
an die verbraucher weitergibt das wäre
auch zielführend weil natürlich die
preissteigerungen dazu führen dass
wiederum der verbrauch sinkt und diesen
effekt diese reaktion auf die preise
brauchen wir dringend weil wir haben ja
auch schon darüber diskutiert wir müssen
sparen wo immer es geht und wenn wir die
preise künstlich niedrig halten wollen
würden also niedriger als sie eigentlich
markt getrieben wären dann wird nicht
genug eingespart das heißt wir müssen
die preise weitergeben müssen dann
diejenigen entlasten die davon besonders
hart getroffen sind aber sollte neben
gleichzeitig dafür sorgen dass die
versorgung weiter geht also entsprechend
muss man auch die versorger die
unternehmen die die gasversorgung
organisieren in dem fall stützen und
kann dann hoffen dass im endeffekt dies
ein vorübergehendes liquiditätsproblem
ist das wieder abnimmt wenn die preise
dann am ende wieder sinken als über den
preis zum sparen zwingen müller hat uns
einen kommentar per mail geschickt
deutschland sollte endlich aufhören sich
wie ein drogensüchtiger zu benehmen der
bei seinem dealer um den nächsten schuss
bettelt ab in den entzug server
geschrieben ich sag mal meinerseits
diese nachrichten die wir jetzt täglich
hören und die angst dass die gaspreise
weiter steigen und das nicht genug
liefert wird betrifft ja
verbraucher die industrie aber sie sorgt
eben auch dafür dass die preise weiter
steigen heizen wir mit dieser hysterie
all das noch zusätzlich an
ein ganz wichtiger punkt den zuschauer
da macht das ist auch ganz früh nach dem
angriff auf die ukraine schon diskutiert
worden
eigentlich hätte man verschiedene
möglichkeiten
russland eben diese möglichkeit zu
nehmen den preis durch diese
unsicherheit die er provoziert wird
immer wieder in die höhe zu treiben da
gibt es verschiedene möglichkeiten die
eine möglichkeit wäre eine importsteuer
so dass ein teil der hohen erlöse dieser
erzielt werden zumindest bei uns
anfangen würde eine andere möglichkeit
wäre ein preis ultimatum dass man eben
nicht mehr zeit an als einen bestimmten
preis zum beispiel 50 euro pro
megawattstunde das immer noch deutlich
mehr als früher mal gezeigt wurde wo der
preis zwischen 10 und 20 euro lag und
dann hätte man eben auch diesen hebel
eliminiert dass der preis in die höhe
getrieben werden kann und russland davon
profitiert und dann eine dritte idee war
treuhandkonten zu nutzen und die gelder
eben nicht direkt auszuzahlen sondern
auf ein treuhandkonto zu legen und erst
dann auszahlen wenn gewisse meilensteine
in der kooperation wieder erreicht sind
was natürlich im moment überhaupt nicht
absehbar ist insofern hätte man
möglichkeiten gehabt ich glaube warum
man das nicht gemacht hat ist dass man
angst hatte dass daneben der lieferstopp
erfolgen würde und es stimmt insofern
schon dass diese sehr hoher respekt vor
dem lieferstopp der natürlich auch
berechtigt ist aber uns hier in diese
bredouille bringt dass wir diese sehr
sehr hohen preise tragen müssen diese
angst vor dem lieferstopp hat eben
verhindert dass man sich dem konsequent
in der art und weise entgegen stellt und
das bedeutet jetzt dass wir aktuell mit
diesem preis schwankungen und diesen
dauernden unsicherheiten auch leben
müssen das ist eine sehr sehr schwierige
situation und ich glaube nicht dass sich
das schnell ändert weil man sieht ja
dass russland strategisch die
lieferungen an und abstellt und immer
versucht ein narrativ aufrechtzuerhalten
dass man ja seine verträge einhält
russland hat ja immer ein vorwand war um
die lieferungen reduziert werden mal das
ist die turbine die gefehlt natürlich
die wartungen war sie wohl jetzt da war
die pipeline abgestellt dann ist es die
termine
2021 hat man nicht mehr geliefert als
vertraglich abgemacht war in den
langfristigen verträgen natürlich hat er
noch mehr entziffern konnten aber hat
man nicht
so sind wir eben diese unsicherheit es
ist eben auch ein geschäft mit der angst
dass da betrieben wird natürlich und am
ende lohnt es sich für putin wenn mehr
für gas bezahlt werden muss sie haben
vorhin von dem umlageverfahren
gesprochen und ja auch wir haben es im
beitrag gesehen sozusagen als idee um
damit juniper und andere nicht umfallen
damit man diese preise weitergeben kann
eben an den verbraucher womit rechnen
sie konkret wird hier gefragt und die
zweite wer würde denn von so einem
umlageverfahren betroffen seien nur die
gaskunden oder wird das auf die
gesamtbevölkerung umgelegt
im endeffekt wäre es wahrscheinlich so
dass das auf die gas kunden umgelegt
würde und jetzt gibt es natürlich pro
und contra wir müssen sehen dass wir in
einer sehr herausfordernden
situation sind wo wir das was getan wird
wahrscheinlich nicht komplett fair
ausgestalten können bei dem
umlageverfahren ist natürlich der
vorteil dass der einzelne gründe ich
eine immense preissteigerung erfährt
sondern alle eine mittlere
preissteigerung der nachteil ist
natürlich dass diejenigen zum beispiel
bestraft werden sozusagen die sich
bereits jetzt schon einen versorger
ausgesucht haben vielleicht sogar zu
höheren preisen der eben gerade nicht
russisches gas bezieht und die erwartung
hatten dass sie dadurch ein bisschen das
risiko reduzieren dem sie selbst
ausgesetzt sind ich glaube wir müssen
hier auch eine gewisse solidarität
zeigen weil man kann in dieser kürze der
zeit keinen mechanismus finden
wahrscheinlich der dazu führt dass
gespart wird dass wir die gas lücke
möglichst niedrig bekommen und das
wirklich jeden vorbehalt
dass man wirklich jeden vorbehalt
gerecht wird insofern ist das eine sehr
herausfordernde lage und das
umlageverfahren ist wahrscheinlich dass
das noch am einfachsten erlaubt die
preise weiterzugeben und dann eben über
den preiseffekt auch die
verbrauchsmengen so stark zu reduzieren
dass wir nicht alle in eine sehr große
produkt gekommen weil denn die gaswerke
zu groß ist und tatsächlich die
versorgung dann auch bei haushalten
heruntergefahren werden muss das ist
natürlich eine situation die sich in
deutschland niemand wünscht wir können
die sicherlich vermeiden aber dafür
müssen wir eben auch ein paar hebel in
bewegung setzen sie hatten eine
energiespar prämie sozusagen gefordert
oder mal thematisiert habe hat das aber
wieder einkassiert wie ist denn da ihre
ihre sichtweise mittlerweile habeck
sprach heute davon wir brauchen einen
langen atem denn klar ist auch nicht mit
dem nächsten winter ist das thema
erledigt auch nicht mit dem übernächsten
sondern es wird uns länger beschäftigen
wir haben vorhin gehört mindestens bis
2025 bis strukturen geschaffen sind um
das so zu ändern dass wir dass wir so
energie beziehen können wie wir das
möchten die zeit bis dahin was halten
sie für den besten sozial ausgewogen weg
putin hat ein großes interesse auch
daran europa auseinander zu bringen auch
über die unsicherheit die er mit den
gaslieferungen generiert insofern muss
man eigentlich in diesem winter alles
daran setzen so viel wie möglich
einzusparen um sich eben weniger
erpressbar zu machen das stärkt und dann
einerseits den europäischen zusammenhalt
aber es macht auch unwahrscheinlicher
dass wir hier sehr großen
herausforderung ausgesetzt werden weil
es ist ja so interessant da für russland
und diese unsicherheiten auszusetzen um
so abhängiger wir sind also umso weniger
gut wer vorgesorgt haben und vor dem
hintergrund würde ich für diesen winter
eigentlich denken dass so ein
prämiensystem sehr gut wäre weil wenn
man jetzt diese ganzen maßnahmen
ergreift und zusätzlich dann noch
prämien aus schreibt für diejenigen die
besonders viel sparen dann bekommt ja
nicht jeder diese prämie aber jemand der
noch eine besonders gute idee hat wie
ihr gas einsparen kann und sei es dass
er jetzt darüber nachdenkt seine heizung
auszutauschen und das eben dann doch
schafft es zu tun den handwerker findet
und so weiter und so fort der könnte
dann eben auch noch beitragen indem er
eben diese auf diesen aufwand auf sich
nimmt und da in diesem winter ist
wirklich spitze auf knopf steht
potenziell würde ich denken dass in
diesem winter einfach so pragmatische
maßnahmen adäquat werden für die längere
frist bis 2025 müssen wir dann einfach
planen von den gasverbrauch reduzieren
wobei man sich eigentlich keine
illusionen machen dafür werden noch
länger viel gas brauchen einfach
deswegen weil wir natürlich nicht in
großem umfang auf die kohleverstromung
setzen wollen und weil unser strombedarf
insgesamt natürlich zb auch steigt das
heißt im stromsektor wird der
gasverbrauch durchaus mittelfristig auch
noch ansteigen frau professor monika
grimm dankeschön für diese information
für die ihre sichtweise größe nach bonn
und danke für die zeit die sie hatten
abschließend wir haben auf pipelines
geschaut wir schauen natürlich auch ins
portemonnaie aufs konto auf soziale
gerechtigkeit alles wichtig wir haben
hier noch einige fragen wo es darum geht
atomkraftwerke länger laufen zu lassen
warum eigentlich soll es im home-office
energiesparender sein als im büro wo
doch im home-office jeder für
sicherheits und andere auch wie
pipelines funktionieren es bleibt ein
spannendes thema aber vielleicht sollten
wir bei alldem nicht vergessen auch
immer wieder mal auf die ukraine zu
schauen und was dort täglich passiert
und wie man sich dort gezwungenermaßen
auf den nächsten winter vorbereitet
vorbereiten muss mit den gegebenheiten
die es dort momentan gibt in diesem
sinne danke für eure aufmerksamkeit für
die rege teilnahme und bis zum nächsten
mal